[Music]
with the stars on Tom Bergeron and I'm
Erin Andrews it's most memorable year
night lots of Tears Monday night as the
season 20 forecast reflected on the most
challenging times in their lives as they
turn their troubles into triumphs and
expressed it all through dance
[Music]
fifth harmony gave a surprise
performance during normanni Corday's
rumba her most memorable year 2012 when
she joined the girl group I feel like I
can't do enough to even thank them I put
into words how grateful I actually am
for them just because they changed my
life I'm in love with Bonnie I'm in love
with your body every day discovering
something new I'm in love with the shape
of former bachelor Nick vile had an
assist from his fiance Vanessa
during his Rumba with Peta Murgatroyd I
think she did fantastic actually we
rehearsing a couple times we were trying
to time the dip and it was easily our
best dip NFL Pro Rashad Jennings
dedicated his contemporary routine to
his father growing up they had a strange
relationship any time you try to get
closer to him he would turn to alcohol
Rashad's performance was so stunning it
brought him and his father to tears
he also nabbed the first tens of the
season obviously the scores shocked
Rishi I mean I was surprised but
honestly I could have I could have got
zero and I still would feel as good as I
do right now because that was much more
than a dance to me that was me having
poetry in motion
four Olympic gold medalist Simone biles
her most memorable year was 2000 the
year she was adopted by her biological
grandparents it was exciting to have
them there and to go through it with me
I was just crying but I think somewhere
in like the mumbling was I love you 2016
was a scary year for Bonner Bolton he
broke his neck during a bull riding
competition too
moment where you thought this is it oh
my god ah chef his Foxtrot with Sharna
Burgess earned a 32 out of 40 from the
judges we grew a luck this week together
it wasn't an easy week this is so fresh
this story this happened a year ago and
Here I am saying let's do a dance about
it that's hard for someone to go okay I
trust you to do that and here is here's
my heart and soul she's like a dance
therapist but ultimately one dancing
pair was eliminated the couple leaving
right now is mr. t and Kim
[Music]
you